this week we've got spin cycle rescue
school for sale and drive through attack
oh [ __ ] our first story the 74 year-old
woman stumbled and suffered a head and
face injuries while she was hiking in
Arizona's Phoenix mountain preserves
where she gets we're going outside yeah
I never go there the Phoenix Fire
Department rescued her by air lifting
her to a hospital but the video getting
viral it's good it's good video chat
where they pick him up and then he falls
and then no no we got it we gotta watch
this I feel so bad for left I [ __ ]
cried laughing just watch my feet 74
year old lady oh so much
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you guys prepped it though everyone's
like she's 74 that really helps you get
the laugh that I needed like what oh I
hope she was passed out in there dude
all right my head we're good just put me
down I'm okay I feel better I don't like
she's in there she's like oh jesus
[ __ ] straight now I don't even think
the age matters cuz whatever she got
rescued from is it a worse now she might
as well have like driven over a forest
and the sleeping bag is just [ __ ]
hating on every single tree are so
intense you just astronaut training well
it's already scary enough didn't pull it
off by this thing but if I had that [ __ ]
I'm sure she there was a thing in there
like a weed whacker okay though so she's
okay she's treated for dizziness and
doctors had to find her [ __ ] eyes
they thought they found a minute they
found him in her feet back together so
they're saying that what happened was
that the extra thing the Horde cable the
cable that supposed to stabilize that is
snap oh
I want to hear the conversation inside
the helicopter they show they're gonna
release it there Pali cracking up how
can you not especially when there's a
helmet I job not to mention that for her
to stay in there that's good every time
before that company that made that whole
system well I mean not the love in it
yes how strong it is a good thing that
ropes not and not the other room oh I
watch this yesterday and it still
brought me to tears like is there any
commentary from her at all oh I think
cuz we all picture our moms in there
grandma I picture her commentary would
just be like if you smashed your hands
on the keyboard they were able to
stabilize her like doing some sort of
maneuvers and then they took her to a
landing site which was not that far away
but how'd they land I know she's still
spinning like who's caught it and
stabilized very gay obviously but then
it was also because she was going with
the turbine when that's created by the
actual helicopter blade how do they how
do they live so you gotta get it's like
it's like it's like that movie
interstellar bad like McConaughey you
gotta [ __ ] match the speed and the
rotation so they got a [ __ ] guy on a
merry-go-round and they're like someone
around just to get him at the same
[ __ ] yawn saying like how else would
you do it like a kid like I'm finding
his [ __ ] yo-yo yeah they're calling it
she's the rotor wash the turbulence
caused by the rotary wings we had they
were able to somehow stabilize it enough
to land there and then they did
something else and she was speeding all
the way to the hospital no she wasn't
I feel like the thing spins you know
once it gets wound up it finally stops
it should
do can you believe some people pay for
that experience I'd like to go to Space
Camp and all that kind of [ __ ] she have
free space very very go to be a
certified astronaut next story this high
school senior in ordered like his idea
of a senior prank instead of like making
a mess
oh no maybe it's a good thing he's
donating to a homeless shelter I don't
know anyway go so he decided to do
something a little bit more chill which
was to post the school for sale on
Craigslist
oh I'd want to buy a school that's who
did it interested it's going on sale for
twelve thousand two hundred and seventy
five dollars oh I buy it as cheap what
you're doing this [ __ ] if he should have
sold it for his year his I sold it for
his graduation here like 2000's in there
imagine you have a school that's so much
square feet you have a full kitchen you
have some basketball court yes points
here is newly-built football fields
newly added for modern-day rooms next to
Walmart for convenient huh huge parking
lot great for party goers looking for
somewhere to park bigger than normal
dining room reason for sale is due to
lots of students coming up and named
after the hometown resident US president
harry s truman and his family and so
that whole thing the police department
investigated the craigslist ad because
the school was like the school contact
of the police because of the the part
that says loss of students that comment
oh come on I said what graduating you
[ __ ] that's what the students said
but this the school administrators did
not they took that they took it as an
implied threat oh so they took it as
students dying yes so they said that's a
stretch they just want a reason to get
this kid in trouble yeah I hate this guy
cuz he was a sh t was pretty funny
mm-hmm so they're trying to just like
they were relate relating it all back to
the recent school shootings so they said
that whether or not it's real or implied
it
so really imply threat they will face
discipline so the student has faced
discipline
oh no they're saying that they will have
extra police officers for the remainder
of the school year shut I'll have
additional officers at graduations at
all of their high schools because of it
they will make sure to suck the fun out
of all of it hmm
I mean late that just means that they
are so super paranoid about school
shootings that they just made this
problem happen that way it kind of made
his brain even more epic now it's all
over the news many people are standing
by him he sells car insurance for a
living he looks like he works at Harry
Potter world that's crazy man what is
this world coming to
that's a good Frank though it is a good
prank yeah what are those pranks that
you're like oh that's clever man good
job like the funny ones that like the
actual good ones that nobody gets hurt
and no one exactly yeah those are funny
not like the red cups scene [ __ ] you or
whatever have you seen this the red cups
and the chain-link fence and it's like
[ __ ] this school oh yeah like they make
a word out of your prank did you guys
see what senior prank at your schools
I did one what did you do I think we
just spray-painted neon orange dicks are
everywhere oh is that capitalism Frank I
didn't partake like these they feel like
the principal's car and put it on the
roof well like that's all that's in
movies and [ __ ] I never yeah how do you
do them really I mean that's literally
illegal you stole a car there's one that
they they put like they got like half a
car they bought it from a junkyard or
something oh you didn't XO Walt and then
they they painted the walls make it look
like there was a hole in rubble all
right cool we talked about it in news oh
yeah like [ __ ] like that
Oh clever vandalism yeah now like we
filled the principal's car with sand a
hundred percent sand that's actually
pretty good too but dude that's like
that's a [ __ ] the cars ha ha that's
pretty good yeah he was saying that
other people had ideas of creating the
front lobby into a beach oh cool yeah
where they get the money yeah right
expensive what is their family owns like
a [ __ ] sand business and did they
have all the fat in the world
all right last story a driver was
waiting in a Taco Bell drive-thru in San
Diego when this homeless lady walked up
to him and stuck a syringe in his hands
[ __ ]
cuz that urban legend yeah it's scary
yeah it's the AIDS virus dies the moment
hits air such an area so you that's yeah
so you're fine with that you know how do
you know that that's better read up on
it that's time that makes me feel better
well I thought that's how you get it by
sharing needles
oh cool there's still blood in the
needles when the blood goes back all the
bloods in the needle remember when we
got our IV to do that but then yeah
we're still if there were someone there
like it's the one that you're talking
about like how like they put needles in
theater chairs and [ __ ] then you sit on
it yeah I remember that
urban urban legend
they put aids in the the needle that
prints there can you sit down you get
AIDS
Oh like sewing needles or like if you go
into like a payphone
remember those ancient relics and then
you look for change you put your finger
inside you get prettier or like if you
play basketball with someone who has
AIDS you get AIDS yep that's that's what
they would get thought that's why
everyone yeah right exactly that's why
Magic Johnson was so good as in one of
the girls in the novella she had HIV and
then like everyone near her like she had
no friends because no one wanted him to
even be near her because they thought
that the bubonic so when she sneeze like
you think yeah biggest drama scene ever
I love novella
I would jump in a pool cuz the chlorine
kills it yeah yeah so this guy his name
is Ralph he now has to take blood tests
for seven months
Oh to make sure he didn't get any
diseases and he also has to pay more
than 3000 in medical bills so you're
saying that the woman just was acting
very erratically and that he was just
waiting for his order at the drive-thru
so then the woman started talking to him
well he doesn't even work there he was
waiting in his car buying food at the
drive-thru yeah and so he said all of a
sudden she pulled up her left hand which
had a bag in a syringe right here with
the needle sticking out she pushed my
hand into the car and when she pushed my
hand into my car the syringe entered the
side of my hand and then the woman just
wandered off nothing about del Taco ha
nope that's serious [ __ ] because this
Taco Bell I know that's why oh that
could be any of us waiting for their
Taco Bell not joke yeah
you don't like to talk about nope you
think Jesse Zubin San Diego did he still
get his order
hell yeah what do you do like I'll get a
car and punch her yeah that's my natural
reaction first off why you sparking
conversation yeah I know some people
though they're like well they're human
too and like they're harmless I'm like
that too like just like the normal like
not the ones are screaming crazy you
know but acting erratically yeah that's
how people die did you know how many
people die cuz they're being nice to
somebody it's like it's like they're
being followed by somebody and they
decide not to run they're like exactly
that's how you get [ __ ] up like if
they ask for change no it's fine like I
don't ignore them you should be no I
don't think you should ignore them
that's [ __ ] up dude dude is so great
Nicky was telling me that so in her
neighborhood she was walking one morning
oh no this guy no it's not her it's this
guy he likes skateboarded up like around
her or something and then and and then
he went away and then all of a sudden
she sees him up in the end of the street
and he skateboards and stops at the end
of the street and she just immediately
know in terms of [ __ ] just goes the
other way like not know politeness not
like I'm gonna cross the street or
whatever it's just like hey so you know
my intentions are [ __ ] you gosh it's
creepy and you didn't follow her I think
living in downtown LA will make you a
mean person
well no it's cuz I read this thing about
like homeless people and they're always
like the worst part of being homeless
like a special readers like a regular
guy that just came on hard time so we're
seeing about being homeless is when
people treat you like you don't even
exist
but imagine being panhandled to nine
times a day yeah well I mean like I'm
still gonna say sorry no but yeah crazy
nights yeah I don't acknowledge them
yeah you don't exist
you're very easy then I won't say
anything but if it's just like a dude
ask for money I'll always say no and
have a nice day or whatever I say man if
I have energy he does the door thing
where he goes black oh that guy was
crazy what guy guy I told this story
before I've never heard the story in
barbel I think right no no no so real
quick I was driving out of my my garage
place and then this guy came up
radically and he was [ __ ] yelling at
me and all this [ __ ] and he was like you
got moiré and he was at my door like
this so then I opened up the door real
quick and went BAM to his face and
closed the door drove off whoa scary
what's he thinks gonna happen
you got money yeah man it was right he
was crazy he was on drugs I was he
expecting right I mean you could have
just drove away but I like that you were
like they need to calm it was like a bee
that was coming to close and I had a go
like that maybe he was reading a
personal development book and it's like
you have to demand what you want okay
yeah I'll try that out
[Music]
[Music]